This tiny little wafer thin chip
could be a better way to explore
space
than the
gold rush to space we can say
we're like the shovel.
Once upon a time Natalya Bailey
had big dreams of working for NASA.
I would sleep on my trampoline
at night and watch the stars
and thinking about aliens
and watching the Space Station
pass overhead
and I went on
to apply to NASA twice
to become an astronaut
and have gotten there thanks
but no thanks.
Postcards from NASA
but I'll keep applying.
So she had to settle for being a
plain
old rocket scientist
and a founding member of Accion
systems
a startup poised to revolutionize
space travel
with these wafer thin chips that
believe
it or not our engines.
Low earth orbit is
becoming more
and more accessible to organizations
universities hobbyists
and their garages,
people that before never would have
even
imagined launching a satellite.
So we're talking about you know
tens of thousands of satellites
being
launched over the next decade
and currently they have no
propulsion
solutions.
And that's what Accion is building
as
is an engine that works on
small satellites.
OK this is actually rocket science,
so here's the bare minimum
you need to know- an ion
is a charged atomic particle
by pushing ionic liquid which is
basically
a molten salt into this chip
the size of a penny billions of ions
can be discharged at mind boggling
velocities.
If you could picture an astronaut
sitting on the back of a satellite
and she's throwing tennis balls off
the back,
each time she throws a tennis ball
off
the satellite moves a little bit in
the opposite
direction. In Accion's engine these
tennis balls are actually ions,
and our smallest ion
engine is about the size of a pack
of cards.
Now we still need conventional
rockets to escape
Earth's gravity.
But once in space Accion's chip
will increase the shelf life of
satellites by
years,
and eventually enable deep space
travel
without chemical propulsion
rockets. Our engines operate without
any
fire flames
or loud noises so
they're not quite as visceral as say
a Falcon Heavy rocket for
example, but they're very efficient.
This is a Berkut.
It's a canard pusher
and it's kind of like our family
car.
I've always wanted to
be an astronaut.
And aviation is kind
of like the next best thing.
Fortunately I married a pilot
and were raising the youngest pilot
here.
First electric propulsion engines
were actually developed in the 50s
and 60s
but they were largely ignored after
that,
and it seemed to me during college
that
there was this whole branch of
rocket
science just waiting to be advanced.
Natalya's studies accelerated at
such
a rapid pace she had to learn what
it meant
to own a business while still a
student
of science.
I don't think business comes
naturally to me.
I was in a lab
at MIT trying to finish up
experiments
with headphones on listening to
how to be a startup CEO
and trying to learn on the
job essentially.
Our
serious long term customers
are right now people like the
Department
of Defense and folks like Lockheed
Martin and Boeing.
But our first fight delivery that
went
out the door was actually to Irvine
high school.
So a group of high school students
is going to be launching a cube sat
with our system on it.
After hawking these chips to
everyone from
school kids to the Department of
Defense,
Natalya envisions Accion playing an
even
larger role in space exploration.
Shoot for Mars
or
Alpha Centauri.
It's pretty a B Hag, a Big Hairy
Audacious Goal.
Is that sort of like your whole
career bascially?
Yes.
Why would you have any other way?